and this morning we take you to a tiny
village in south africa that's been
overrun really by thousands of people
searching for diamonds the crowds poured
in after a man reported finding
a crystal-like stone in a field africa
by the way produces most of the world's
diamonds but not
in this area as deborah patter reports
that is not stopping
these poor people from trying to dig
their way to a better life
started with a chance discovery and
quickly turned into a mass treasure hunt
once word got out that a local herdsmen
had dug up what might be a precious
stone
thousands of fortune seekers flocked to
the small rural village in kwazulu-natal
i heard that people are taking diamonds
here so i said no
let me come and take a try only to find
it i was going to find one
most people here have no idea what an
uncut diamond looks like
i haven't seen or touched a diamond in
my life said
i hope this makes a difference because
we're really struggling
authorities have sent experts to the
area a geologist on site was skeptical
telling us
it's unlikely these are diamonds but
that hasn't stopped people from dreaming
if this were the real diamonds that will
help me
and my family because everyone needs a
financial stability and
everyone needs to get up in life teams
of geologists have collected stones for
further investigation
the south african economy has taken a
severe battering during the pandemic
which is why this modern-day diamond
rush has sparked
such high hopes for a better life for
cbs this morning
deborah patter johannesburg
that is quite a scene you know i mean
and you can
you can understand why people would hear
a story about someone getting rich
finding something in the dirt and
flocking to that spot but
i don't think those are diamonds they're
finding it doesn't look like it to me
but what if they
are maybe that's the dream that is the
dream that's the dream if that was
nearby
i might jontro over there and dig
through the dirt i know it's very
tempting let's take a shot